okay and we do have a guest in the
studio with us Victor michalevski I
haven't seen you in so long I know we
used to play in the US a lot we actually
have played so it's nice to see you
again uh so you had a
um draw with the white pieces so what do
you think were the key moments in this
game in fact I won on time but it was oh
he went on time
yeah
I did not realize that
um okay so let's take a look at the game
so you played this position so you
decided not to play with the three four
and then
at some point you got some kind of a
double fiance benoni yeah well I think
this position should be better for white
because of your nice Pawn structure and
yeah and the bishop on B7 is bad so
yeah but then I problem split it
so all of this still looks very nice for
you
yeah
but but then I wasn't so sure how to
play this position
so I mean this is
in the center yeah it looks logical but
so four
so what do you think about this before
move uh probably before was inaccurate
but uh two months later I just made a
bad move I think after A5 was correct
Queen did and now I think Knight D1 was
a mistake I completely forgot that I'm
not in time to play Knight d2c4 like the
game probably I had to play like Knight
B1 my initial idea was even to sacrifice
the pawn with Knight A4
Knight is coming to C4 and so that's
very nice oh yeah that's a nice
combination yeah or or even Bishop G7
Knight B2 Knight C4 like this I was like
this way right all night
b2c49 is coming and so that's really
nice but then when when we got this
position I thought why should they give
the spawn I can just play 91 and play
same position as equal pawns but then
after he played Knight F6 I realized I
cannot play Knight D2 just he takes the
D5 Pawn oh yes I guess that's what I
forgot about it oh that's unfortunate
and they cannot play 93 as well because
A4 Pawn is hanging
oh so you forgot that immediately the
night no I I saw Knight F6 I thought I
can play Knight G2 and forgot about the
D5 Pawn okay
okay let's play rookie too yeah I
thought I need to protect the Rook so I
can play Knight d2c4 maybe an ID tonight
E3 yeah H5 was interesting in fact so he
is kind of preventing id2 because then
he can go H4 I could probably still play
it and the allow H takes G3 but
probably still good for me but
reunited yeah this is hanging already
yeah but I try to get the same position
with without even allowing H4
so I played King G1 yeah with the idea
of playing H4 so we're actually
wondering is it possible yeah I think 94
was very sharp I wasn't sure because I
think I should play Bishop G2 that was
my idea obviously too yeah because if I
play Knight G5 instead I think he can
sacrifice the queen Knight takes
seven Knight F3 checking G2 and Rook
takes E7 and they cannot take the Knight
because of Bishop takes D5 and that gets
Checkmate oh wow this is beautiful
wow this is really nice
and so ah 991 is a huge threat maybe you
need to go I could go to H1 but then he
just takes rookie seven and oh this D5
is hanging
yeah
yeah but I wasn't so happy about this
position frankly yeah like he has a rook
Rook Knight and the pawn for the queen
and a nice position I think so that's
why I was going to play Bishop G2
instead instead of Knight G5 this idea
of Knight G5 and here I wasn't so sure
he has some moves like I don't know
Bishop takes B2 Maybe
I think I should take with the light oh
this is defended okay yeah because I I
need the Knight on e4 to be attacked and
now if Queen F6 I can play Rook a31 that
was my idea and tonight is still pinned
oh yeah
yeah
and just Knight G5 I think wow this is
so sharp yeah I wasn't sure no but here
it looks like you're winning a piece
right probably here I'm winning a piece
but yeah I wasn't so sure I thought he
will play 94.
so he won Knight G4 instead he took the
Knight G5
yeah
I think this position should be good for
weight yeah so here you're already
getting everything you wanted ready
because yeah Knight to C4 yeah
still I was short on time and wasn't so
sure I had to convert
yeah maybe rookie one was too slow I
don't know
because he started to
so in this position why did you decide
to go for E5 just because it was short
I thought maybe a form yeah maybe it
works yeah but then he may have check
maybe rookie seven I wasn't so sure or
just rookie seven right away
so on can we kick the coin away yeah
something like this yeah but then I'm
not sure how I'm making progress here
because I don't know if I can play A5
maybe it'll just be a conversion because
it looks like after E5 no yeah
yeah
now it's forced Queen before Bishop D5
rookie five
and then here he lost in time and move
40. yeah we thought
it was just a draw because it was more
40 but yeah that's very unfortunate but
here okay you're up a pond but no no you
can play Rook B7 instead of taking on G2
in fact
no like later after rookie five Rook B7
hi okay yeah and then yeah just gets it
back immediately yeah
okay well I mean yeah I mean it's a win
yeah I know it's not the way you would
want to win but yeah yeah that's very
unfortunate and yesterday you had a very
interesting game you played at King's
Indian with a pan soccer player it was a
very instructive game where um with your
a pawn but eventually I saw that and the
dinner yeah I could have even lost this
thank you for joining us and good luck
in the rest of your games and we'll hope
to see you back here again thank you and
let's continue